[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal voici
les titres de ce jeudi 1er juin 10e
édition du trophée des entreprises à
saint quentin en yvelines les
participants s'affrontent sur l'île de
loisirs et le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin avec des épreuves de
course à pied d'orientation de radeaux
et de vtt montigny le bretonneux vient
de recevoir le titre de ville amie des
enfants de la part de l'unicef
récompensant la politique menée
quotidiennement par la ville en
direction des enfants
un label créé en 2002 pour promouvoir et
faire respecter des droits de l'enfant
au niveau local forte de ces bons
résultats au premier tour de la
présidentielle la france
insoumise de jean luc mélenchon espère
confirmer pour législatives et notamment
dans la conscience circonscription le
mouvement est arrivé en 2e classe
derrière emmanuel macron et même en tête
dans les communes de la verrière et rap
bonsoir nous commençons ce journal par
les obsèques des manuels lamy le maire
de saint germain en laye célébrées
aujourd'hui à l'église saint germain
emmanuel lamy est décédé d'un accident
vasculaire cérébral à l'âge de 69 ans il
avait pris les rênes de la commune en
en succédant à michel péricard la
cérémonie a eu lieu en présence de
valérie pécresse présidente de la région
que gérard larcher président du sénat
pierre bédier président du département
et aussi jean michel fourgous le maire
d'elancourt
c'est une véritable tradition pour la
dixième année consécutive le trophée des
entreprises est organisée ce jeudi en
fin d'après midi sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
notre journaliste michael et demi
d'euros et sur place et il nous présente
le concept de cette compétition sportive
qui réunit une cinquantaine
d'entreprises comme vous pouvez le voir
le départ sera donné dans quelques
minutes juste derrière moi le concept
est simple 5 140 compétiteurs classés en
trois catégories hommes femmes et mixtes
vont courir par équipe de trois et comme
selon indique la compétition compte
les entreprises ces dernières sont
essentiellement issus du territoire des
yvelines on retrouve par exemple
l'entreprise airbus d'elancourt des
teams du technocentre renault de
guyancourt ou encore la poste de saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya également une école qui sera
présente avec le collège einstein de
magny les hameaux ou encore des mairies
comme celle de trappes
comme tous les ans la compétition se
déroule à travers l'île de loisirs
petite particularité cette année les
participants s'élancent du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
le site qui accueillera peut-être les jo
en 2024
les compétiteurs devront aussi être en
forme olympique pour disputer la
compétition
au programme 1 5 km de course à pied il
y aura également deux points 5 km2 avec
dix balises à pointer ce qui ne devrait
pas être une mince affaire pour nos
compétiteurs
il faudra aussi être à l'aise sur l'eau
avec une épreuve dorado de 500 m les
sportifs termineront avec un relais de
vtt 6 de plus d'1 65 km avant de
terminer par un bike and run les
meilleurs devraient terminer la
compétition
dans un peu moins d'une heure on prend à
présent la direction de
montigny-le-bretonneux la ville a
décroché en mars dernier le label ville
amie des enfants
décerné par l'unicef france le document
officiel a été signé ce mercredi à
l'occasion d'un unis des un événement de
sensibilisation sur les droits de
l'enfant
la journée a mobilisé plus d'une
centaine de jeunes âgés de 3 à 10 ans
reportage michael et demi d'euros c'est
officiel montigny le bretonneux la 12e
ville du département à se voir décerner
le label ville amie des enfants
une distinction accordée par l'unicef le
fonds des nations unies pour l'enfance
et deux parties ont signé la charte ce
mercredi 31 mai au square du poirier
saint martin lee addy fiche spéciale aa
renseigner sur le handicap sur la façon
de vivre sur la santé sur l'éducation
dans le dossier de montigny je crois que
ce qui fait la différence ce qui fait
que on peut accepter montini comme ville
amie des enfants c'est qu'à travers ce
dossier on voit la solidarité que veut
exprimer la ville par rapport aux aux
enfants par rapport aux enfants de
toutes les races de toutes les cultures
j'irai aux fins
enfin la politique menée par la ville de
monthey en direction de leur enfance et
reconnu à son juste niveau
pour rappel que nous travaillons bien
sûr sur le cd politique est là depuis
très longtemps sur le terrain ce
partenariat va permettre de réaliser des
journées de sensibilisation comme ce fut
le cas avec les unis dès ce mercredi
l'événement organisé par le conseil des
jeunes de la ville et l'unicef a permis
à travers des jeux et des panneaux
informatifs d'expliquer les droits des
enfants
l'enfant apprend à travers les jeux
l'enfant à travers apprend à travers le
fait d'être en bonne santé de savoir
avoir les notions d'hygiène nécessaires
l'importance de la vaccination pour
éviter les les maladies l'importance
d'aller à l'école pour apprendre là pour
apprendre le devenir de deux des nations
de comment progresser dans la vie on ne
peut pas progresser sans éducation
le label ville amie des enfants est
valable jusqu aux prochaines élections
municipales de 2020
montigny-le-bretonneux devra alors
constituer un dossier pour prolonger
l'aventuré avec l'unicef
si mathurin lévis créa la surprise dans
la 11e sur cette circonscription promis
un duel entre benoît hamon et jean
michel fourgous la france
insoumise a ses chances un constat posé
poser suite aux résultats de jean luc
mélenchon sur ce territoire
reportage nicolas d'angrie le candidat
de la france insoumise va-t-il surfer
sur la vague de jean luc mélenchon dans
la 11e circonscription avec près de 25%
des voix lors du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle le candidat
insoumis arrive en tête rattrapent avec
plus de 32 % des suffrages pour défendre
le projet de l'avenir en commun mathurin
lévis se lance dans les législatives le
score de jean luc mélenchon sur la
circonscription c'est un très bon
résultat
ça prouve qu'il ya sur cette
circonscription des milliers de citoyens
qui sont convaincus qu'il faut que notre
société empreinte un grand changement
économique social politique écologique
etc
donc il faut capitaliser sur ces
électeurs là tous les électeurs qui ont
voté pour jean luc mélenchon au premier
tour de l'élection présentielle retrouve
un bulletin de vote de la france a
soumis ce qui porte ce projet politique
invité d'honneur pour analyser les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
le sociologue emmanuel todd pour lui
l'électorat de la france insoumise est
interclassiste les quartiers populaires
mais pas seulement
sa vraie force et là c'est d'être
effectivement
c'est essentiel d'avoir une prise sur
les quartiers populaires mais si on veut
aller quelque part il faut avoir une
prise sur les catégories intermédiaires
sur les classes moyennes est l'une des
caractéristiques de l'électorat béland
chaud c'est sa jeunesse justement
donc je pense qu'il faudra croiser les
variables de profession et d'argent pour
comprendre exactement ce qui se passe
deux inquiétudes pour mathurin lévis la
gauche part divisée en quatre
candidatures et le niveau de
l'abstention dans les quartiers
populaires pour les élections
législatives de 2012 elle avait atteint
plus de 43 % des inscrits dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines dans la 12e
circonscription des yvelines le fn sera
représentée par jean luc galles est déjà
candidat aux élections départementales
de 2015 il se présente cette année pour
les législatives ancien directeur
financier il est retraité depuis trois
ans ça fait 35 ans qu'il habite dans la
circonscription le fn ferait représenter
la principale force d'opposition à la
politique d' emmanuel macron jean-luc
galets insiste sur l'enjeu national de
cette élection législative on les écoute
le mandat de député est un mandat
national même si l'élection est local
c'est un mandat national
on doit s'occuper de problèmes nationaux
voter les lois ne pas aller voter
les amendes et faire des propositions
pour améliorer le système législatif
français qui a rencontré un grand nombre
de maires en tant que candidat front
national mais en aucun cas le rôle de
député sera de m'occuper d'affaires
uniquement locale du côté de la 2e
circonscription nous allons maintenant
nous intéresser jean-guy sayus ce
chevrotin est investi par le mouvement
convergence citoyenne
ce candidat se déclare entre libéral
social et social démocrate
les principaux axes de ce candidat
ingénieur de formation la démocratie
citoyenne
il est au micro de mélanie poker se
faire en sorte que en france nous
parvenions à un niveau de satisfaction
de notre gouvernance et du nos
institutions au même niveau
déjà que ceux dont disposent les
allemands avait que 60 % de gens qui
sont favorables à leurs fiers de leurs
institutions et les bars pratique
et puis encore mieux donc les suisses 75
% on propose d'abord que en dernier
recours dès qu'il ya un débat
débat qui suscite de l'émotion comme ce
que l'on a connu par exemple un appel à
leur travail mais on pourrait en citer
d'autres
et bien ce soit les citoyens qu'ils
soient impliqués là dessus et maintenant
l'agenda politique
nous commençons par la troisième
circonscription avec nicolas tradi
joubert divers droite qui sera ce soir à
20h30 au chesnay à la salle des fêtes
dans la 2e circonscription pascal
thévenot pour les républicains sera ce
soir à 20h30 salle dunoyer de ségonzac à
viroflay 2e circonscription toujours
avec jean noël barrot de la république
en marche sera à 20h30 à la salle de la
mairie de toussus le noble
et enfin pour la première
circonscription didier ben asher le
candidat de la république en marche sera
dimanche 4 juin à la pièce d'eau des
suisses à versailles à midi
partons au marché la fête internationale
des marchés s'est terminée le dimanche
28 mai la ville de wimereux notamment à
participer à cette troisième édition des
marchés de village qui attire toujours
autant de monde à la recherche de
produits frais et aussi pour l'ambiance
direction la bergerie de villepreux avec
nicolas landry aucune ride pour le
marché de la et bergeries de villepreux
poissonnier fromager bouchée de nombreux
commerçants présents depuis plusieurs
années comme daniel duterte sur le
marché depuis 1972 à la retraite elle
transmet le témoin à son fils stéphane
marché voilà c'est convivial les gens ce
qu'ils ont besoin
on est enfin lancée absolument surtout
surtout très très conviviale et des très
très bon produit et ce qui est très très
agréable aussi ses concerts les enfants
de nos clients dont elle a les enfants
on a les petits enfants auxquels
clientèle de marché fidèle cliente du
marché mireille vient tous les samedis
elle achète sa viande et ses légumes
moi je viens au marché pour sa
essentiellement pour trouver des
produits locaux des produits de qualité
il ya un climat de confiance qui
s'instaure entre
le commerçant et le client c'est ça n'a
rien d'anonyme jonas cochet est chargé
de gérer le marché des emplacements des
commerçants au règlement des litiges
il note une fréquentation toujours élevé
du marché de du pr maintenant on vient
pour le produit pour la qualité et aussi
pour le relationnel avec les avec les
commerçants et les autres clients tout
simplement quand ils attendent chez des
commerçants justement ça permet aussi
créer un lien un lien donc affectif et
permet aussi par rapport aux personnes
âgées aussi de garder le contact
c'est très important sauce d'après une
étude de l'insee sur la dernière
décennie de moins en moins de français
font leurs courses sur les marchés ils
étaient près de 6% en 2011
ce week-end profiter des espaces verts
avec les rendez vous aux jardins en
mille de france dans les yvelines
plusieurs domaines ouvrent leurs portes
au public comme le domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles que nous vous
faisons découvrir dans ce reportage de
camille lambert
[Musique]
un écrin de verdure discret comme un
joyau à l'abri des regards le domaine de
madame elisabeth 8 hectares de jardins
romantiques au coeur de la cité royale
pour sa première participation au rendez
vous aux jardins et paroles de jardinier
il se dévoile aux visiteurs des
animations culinaires des animations de
décoration florale mais également des
producteurs et des pépiniéristes des
yvelines avec bien entendu une touche un
petit peu sucré avec des produits un
producteur de miel et de l'éco pâturages
donc beaucoup d'animations pour petits
et grands
j'ai toujours une pensée assez douces
pour madame elisabeth qui était un
personnage qui vivaient dans ce dans ce
beau domaine qui comme vous le savez
était la soeur cadette de louis saez
elle était très amoureuse de la nature
donc ça sera notre marraine pour ces
deux jours là un domaine sans pesticides
depuis plus de dix ans
les jardiniers s'engage dans le respect
de la nature ils feront découvrir leur
travail avec un détour par l'orangerie
et son laboratoire d'expériences en
plein air un vivier de plantes
aromatiques
tout est comestible dans quasiment un
jardin ce ce qui est appréciable c'est
qu'on peut manger donc du jardin à
l'assiette quasiment donc on prend une
plante on la goûte on la savoure on a
l'odeur
il y aura une association qui fera
découvrir
des tisanes comment on peut faire avec
son jardin des tisanes personnel donc
avec une culture avec une cueillette sur
place et après une préparation en salle
se soigner grâce à la sauge ou à la
mélisse un privilège royal désormais
accessible à tous l'orangerie ouvrira
également sa première exposition sur des
jardins connecter à découvrir dès les 3
et 4 juin
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver sur tv fier de soixante
dix huit points com ou sur l'application
tv fil 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]